Africa is part of the global economy is
one of the global politics so what
happened in Europe will not just remain
in Europe will have some proportion
consequences or benefits in the African
continent
[Music]
for a lot of Asian countries and I think
including in clear breakfast it is boots
or threatened an opportunity it is a
threat because it's destabilizing our
current relationship with both Britain
and the European Union it is also an
opportunity because it means that
previously delayed trade deals for
example between countries in Asia and
Europe can perhaps be sped up either
independently with Britain or with the
European Union in general if Britain was
perhaps one of the countries that was
objecting to some positive in the Europe
wide trade deal the perception that
although we are very interleague the
cotton finest we have all this
fragmentation no it's certainly true
that the UK in the u.s. hasn't had a
special relationship I think that they
had it before the UK joined the EU they
had it while the UK was in the EU
they'll have it even if the UK leaves I
guess there and I do think that the UK
u.s. relationship if the UK is able to
extricate it something you the UK us
relationship will probably become even
stronger and closer if you look at the
European Union itself Britain actually
was one of the countries that pushed the
African issues and agenda in the
European Union so and it contribute
towards the the fund that is used by
European Union to assist some African
countries without Britain in the EU that
probably will affect the priorities of
the EU itself towards Africa for many
Asian countries in the Pakistan some in
the Gulf there are many of us who
work in Britain and we many of us have
relatives in Britain as well and many of
our relatives were in fact propensity
because there was this belief prior to
the referendum that if you cut down on
migration from the European Union that
will open up the possibility of more
migration from the rest of the world
literally the UK you you know divorce
through brexit it's causing a little
bump in their relationship but I mean I
just I don't think anybody is thinking
this is gonna evolve in a direction of
hostility it's just we need to come up
with a new friendly relationship and it
might not be as close as it once was but
it will still be there it will still be
strong
[Music]